The Joe Rogan experience.
So what was the motivation behind creating this book America before?
It's a curious mixture of things.
I have been exploring the possibility of a lost civilization for more than 25
years.
That was the essence of my book,
fingerprints of the Gods that was published in 1995 that there has been a huge
forgotten episode in human history.
I continued to follow that in a series of other books and by the time I got to
2002 when I published a book called underworld that followed seven years of
scuba diving on continental shelves,
looking for structures that were submerged by rising sea levels.
At the end of the last ice age,
I really felt I'd done it.
I felt I'd walked the walk,
I'd put put out to the public,
a massive body of information and I thought,
my role in this is over and I can breathe a sigh of relief because it's hot in
this particular kitchen and I can go do something else.
And I ended up writing a book about psychedelics.
I ended up writing supernatural meetings with the ancient teachers of mankind.
About the role of psychedelics in,
in the origins of the,
of the human story.
But then new information started to come out that touched on the lost
civilization idea and I couldn't just stand by and ignore that information.
That's why I published and magicians of the Gods in 2015 and then as I was
researching that book,
I became aware of something I hadn't realized before that there's a mass of new
information from the Americas,
specifically from the Americas,
which completely rewrites the story of human history that the Americas,
um,
have been misrepresented,
uh,
for a very long time,
by archaeology.
And archeologist will be annoyed with me for saying that they have a way of
forgetting their own arrows,
uh,
of saying,
Oh,
well,
we knew that all along.
It wasn't,
it wasn't the case,
but the fact of the matter remains that for best part of 50 years from the 1960s
through until about 2010,
American archeology was locked in a dogma that they actually had a name for,
which was Clovis first,
uh,
that they invented a name for a culture.
They call them the Clovis culture.
We don't know what they called themselves.
They were hunter gatherers.
Uh,
they first appear in the archaeological record 13,000,
400 years ago and they vanished from the archeological record 12,000,
600 years ago.
And for a very long time it was maintained adamantly that these were the first
Americans that no human being touched the soil of the Americas until 13,000,
400 years ago.
Just animals.
But no human beings present at all.
And any archeologist who attempted to dispute that dogma,
and I use the word deliberately,
there should be no room for dogma in science,
but any archeologist who challenged that would face severe problems with his or
her career,
they would be mocked and humiliated at conferences like an archeologist called
Jack's hunk Mars from,
from Canada who excavated in the,
in the,
in the Yukon,
humiliated at conferences,
insulted,
accused of making stuff up.
Uh,
their research funding would be withdrawn basically to challenge Clovis first
was the end of your archaeological career.
So naturally,
very few archeologists wanted to challenge Clovis first.
What was this gentleman in the Yukon?
What was is called Jack Sank Mars a and interestingly the Smithsonian,
just in 2017 uh,
did a big kind of mayor Kulpa big admission about this,
that everybody had got things wrong that Jack sank.
Mars had been ruined by the Clovis first lobby,
but he'd been right all along the site.
He excavated in the Yukon,
was re excavated in 2017 and every single thing he said was correct even though
they had just sneered at him.
And what was he,
he was activating in the 1980s in the 1990s he's still alive.
He's still alive.
Yeah.
Better.
Well,
I think he's been indicated,
you know,
and it's kind of,
it's kind of nice to be vindicated that,
that the,
the,
there's almost a place in folklore,
folklore for the,
for the,
for the individual who is scorned and humiliated,
you know,
by,
by others.
But who turns out to be,
to be right.
And He,
and he was right.
But my point about this is that what it meant was,
since it was the dogma that Clovis was first,
that they oldest dates were 13,400 years ago.
There seemed to be no logic to archeologists in digging deeper.
You know,
how it is with archaeology,
that the,
the upper levels are the youngest and the deeper you go,
the older it gets.
That's why we say Upper Paleolithic for the late Ice Age and lower Paleolithic
for the late stone age and lower for the older stone age.
And the feeling was no need to dig below the Clovis layer because we already
know that there were no human beings.
Then before that,
and then a few archeologists I've mentioned Jack Sank Mars,
but uh,
another is I'll Goodyear from the University of South Carolina,
uh,
who excavated a site called topper in South Carolina now.
Now topper is an incredibly rich Clovis site.
It's full of their tools,
their points.
They made these special special Flint points that we used as arrowheads and
spears,
great Clovis site.
He finished excavating the Clovis level and then he did something that was
supposed not to be done.
He decided to dig deeper and he carried on deeping down,
digging down.
And there was a layer of about a meter and a half of of barren soil.
And then beneath that more human artifacts and they finally date those back to
more than 50,000 years ago.
And then in 2017 published in nature,
um,
by Tom Demorais,
who's the chief paleontologist at the San Diego Natural History Museum,
uh,
at a bunch of other very high level,
paleontologists published in nature magazine,
evidence for human presence in North America 130,000 years ago.
Now this is really put the cat amongst the pigeons.
Now,
if humans were oppressed North America 130,000 years ago,
and archeologists have been telling us for 50 years that they were only present
from 13,000 years ago,
that's 10 times as long that we've had humans in North America capable of doing
stuff.
And the archeological dogma has prevented any search for what they were doing
until,
until very recently.
What was the evidence from 130,000 years ago?
Okay.
So what,
it's not the,
let me be clear about this because,
because this is,
this is something that is often misrepresented in,
in my views.
It is not the evidence for an advanced civilization that we find a 130,000 years
ago in America.
The evidence that we find is evidence for human presence and what they were
doing was very much stone age stuff.
It's a Mastodon,
it's a mastodon skeleton.
Uh,
that was,
that was excavated,
was actually found by accident during road construction near CSR near San Diego.
Um,
and,
and an archeologist was attached to the road construction crew and immediately
stopped construction and they investigated it thoroughly.
And what they found was so much dynamite in the early 1990s when they found it
that they decided not to publish at the time because what they found was
evidence that those mastodon bones had been cracked open by human beings using
tools and that the marrow had been extracted,
that one Tusk could be left standing upright in the ground and another had been
left beside it.
That femur had a femur of the animal had been taken away completely from the
site.
Uh,
and there was assemblages of,
of,
uh,
instruments that we use to smash and break the burns.
And the conclusion of the team was that only one kind of creature could have
done that work using tools on a mastodon.
And that's human beings.
That's classic,
classic human behavior.
So this sets the goalposts in a totally different place.
Suddenly we have to consider that humans have been in America for 130,000 years.
We already know that a dogmatic approach of archeology has rather refused to
look at anything older than 13,000 years ago.
And what it does is it generates an engine of demand that we need to be looking
at those missing hundred thousand plus years.
We need to be looking at it hard.
Of course,
the immediate reaction has not been to go looking for stuff in the other hundred
thousand years.
Most archeologists have responded by saying,
this is impossible.
It can't be.
So,
but that's precisely what they said to Jack Sanker Mars who said that humans
were in bluefish caves in the Yukon 25,000 years ago.
And it's precisely what they said to our Goodyear who said humans had been at
topper 50,000 years ago and they were both right.
And I believe that Tom Demorais and his team,
you don't get a big article published in nature unless it's already pretty
solidly based and pretty much peer reviews,
it has produced a reaction.
I would be wrong to say that it's universally accepted.
It's very much challenged.
It's intriguing.
What is the challenge?
The challenge fundamentally comes from we archeologists know that there were no
human beings in the Americas that far back.
To put it in perspective,
it's about 60,000 years before the first evidence of human beings in Europe.
Uh,
it's about 60,000 years before the first evidence of human beings in Australia.
And this is just evidence of the first human beings.
Yes,
we have to point out how difficult it is to find evidence,
extremely difficult to find.
You know,
sometimes we imagine that archeologists are working with masses of skeletal
material,
although they're not,
then they're not.
I mean the whole,
this is one of the ironies,
the whole Clovis first dogma,
you would think that they had masses of material to work with.
They did have the tools,
but in terms of skeletal remains,
just one,
just one single skeletal remains from one of the things that Michael Shermer had
sent me.
Was this a dispute that perhaps the bones had been cracked open by the
excavation material?
Yeah,
I saw excavation machines.
I saw Michael's email email last night and I,
I appreciate that Michael wants to continue to,
uh,
in engage with this subject.
And that's his job.
He's a pro.
He's a professional skeptic and,
and it's his,
his role to do so.
But what he,
what he misses out,
it's true that a new paper has been published,
which raises questions over the,
uh,
what's called the Cerruti Mastodon site,
which is the site that Tom Demorais at San Diego,
actually a museum,
uh,
excavated.
And what's interesting since I can send to Michael,
took the trouble to write the questions.
Can I just,
sure.
Can I just read you something that I responded to them this?
Sure.
Um,
which is that to the microphone?
Those,
yeah.
Yeah.
Basic.
Basically this,
this,
this paper,
um,
was in no way a refutation of the original paper in nature.
As a matter of fact,
the gentleman who wrote that paper never even looked at the archaeological
remains that are in that now in the San Diego Natural History Museum.
Um,
what it is,
what he based it on,
his reference,
I'm quoting from the abstract of the paper itself,
reference to a freeway right of way map and construction plans,
contemporary road building practices and work site photographs available on the
Internet.
In other words,
the site was not visited.
They simply looked at secondary references.
They did not look at the archeological material and they ignore the entire
argument of Tom [inaudible] and his colleagues who had already addressed that
issue.
They didn't look at the bones.
They did not look at the bones.
When you,
when you break a fresh bone,
it has a characteristic kind of spiral fracture that does not happen when you
break a fossilized bone.
And Tom Demorais and his team specifically ruled out road making machinery as
responsible for this breaking pattern because they actually carried out
experiments on a modern elephants,
deceased elephants,
and they broke their bones.
And the kind of fracture that you get in a fresh green bone is completely
different from the kind of lecture you get in a,
in a,
in a fossilized bone.
So unfortunately this paper pays,
pays no attention to that.
It just looks at road plans and says there was roadwork there.
It must have been done by roadwork.
I think it's very sloppy,
very weak and a,
it's certainly not the answer.
We can expect ongoing debate and that is,
uh,
that is healthy.
But this is not a strong case at all.
So this points to the first evidence that we found and is there any effort
underway to try to uncover more evidence that,
uh,
from a similar tone,
I'm going to cite to Tom,
Tom Demorais,
the chief pat intelligence,
the San Diego Natural History Museum.
That's what he would like to see.
He makes the point to me,
I interview him.
I spent a day with him at that actually still museum.
He was very generous with his time.
I did an extended interview and I quote from it in,
in America before,
and his wish is that archeologists,
instead of spending all their time trying to find ways to dismiss and get rid of
his findings,
his wish is that they would spend a little bit of that time looking at deposits
older than 13,400 years,
and even being willing to go back as far as 130,000 years.
That's,
that's would be a proper scientific response.
Here is a thera body of work put forward by a very senior group of scientists
who hesitated before they published it.
They had the information back in the 1990s,
but it wasn't until refined dating techniques later than in the 21st century
that they finally work sure what they had and that they published it in,
in nature in 2017.
It's a,
it's,
it's a,
it's an important study.
Um,
and,
um,
I think what's going to happen,
uh,
is that we're going to find much more evidence of a very ancient human presence
in the America America's,
and that's what Tom Demorais thinks as well.
Um,
and as he points out,
if we don't look,
then we're never going to find,
if we allow dogma to stop us looking and saying,
oh,
it's impossible that humans were in the Americas 130,000 years ago,
so we won't bother to look what a failure of science that is.
And,
and,
and to spend all the time instead of trying to get rid of the evidence that
doesn't fit the current paradigm.
Well,
it's so fascinating that just as fortuitous discovery during a construction site
could change the way people perceive things.
You just got to wonder how much of that stuff is.
And I mean,
how deep did they have to go to find these mastodon bones?
Well,
so this is a,
this is a road cut that's being made.
So those would be,
those would be pretty deep down in 10,
15 feet down.
The greater is going through.
And um,
and flattening them.
It varies from place to place depending on soil deposition,
the stratification,
the stratification of the soil.
But what the key,
the key point is that what you need to do is go deeper than 13,400 years ago and
you need to do so with,
um,
dedication and vigor and with some kind of funding at the moment,
archeology doesn't,
doesn't see the point of that.
If,
um,
the paper in nature,
uh,
by Tom Demorais was alone.
If there were nothing else than that,
uh,
I wouldn't place so much trust in it.
But I've spent a lot of time during the researching of this book with
archeologists who dig did,
Dick did dig deeper.
And what those archeologists all confirm is that there have been human beings in
the Americas for tens of thousands of years.
And it's not surprising that that can be pushed back to a 130,000 years ago.
Because part of the argument about the peopling of the Americas has to do with a
place that we now call the Bering straits between Alaska and Siberia,
which during the Ice Age where at times,
uh,
Landbridge they were exposed because of,
because of lowered sea levels,
but migrants who crossed that land bridge from Siberia on many occasions,
over periods of tens of thousands of years would find themselves confronted then
by the North American ice cap,
which oddly wasn't at the tip of Alaska,
but began further in.
So there was living space in a bit of Alaska,
but you couldn't get through the ice mountains.
These,
these literally ice mountains to two miles deep covering the whole of North
America and preventing access to the and glaciated,
uh,
parts of America.
The thing is that what happened around 13,000,
400 years ago,
there had been a period of global warming and the ice sheets began to melt and a
corridor opened up between what's called the Cordelia and I sheet and the
Laurentide ice sheet.
The two major ice keeps in North America and it's thought that that migration
came through that corridor.
Well,
the thing is that exactly the same thing happened between 140,000 years ago and
120,000 years ago there was an episode of global warming and ice free corridor
opened up and the same opportunity to enter the Americas was there at that
period than it was at the later period.
And Tom Demaris point in mind is that we have to pay much more attention to that
air early appeared.
And that's really why I've gone ahead and uh,
and,
and written this book is to try to put before a broad general audience hopefully
in,
in language that,
that that makes sense and an assembly of all the latest information that casts
doubt on the story we've been told.
Because my goodness,
if archeology is wrong about the story of the peopling of the Americas,
if it's radically wrong as it now appears to be,
then our whole understanding of human history has to change.
It's not just the history of the Americas,
it's the history of the entire world.
It has been an absolute article of faith amongst archeologists that civilization
began in the old world.
And uh,
indeed,
I have a,
I have a book in my library called history begins at summa and it's by Samuel
Noah Kramer are very renowned archeologists.
Uh,
and it's a,
it's a good book actually,
but the argument is that this is where civilization began in the culture that we
call the Sumerians in Mesopotamia between the Tigress and the Euphrates rivers
and that it began about 6,000 years ago.
And that civilization is entirely an invention of the old world and it has
nothing to do with the new world at all because the new world was populated so
late.
This has,
this has been the,
this has been the argument and this is the argument that now radically and
suddenly begins to change that the Americas,
this enormous landmass resource,
rich bountiful in,
in every way south of Minnesota,
south of the ice cap,
vast land areas that are,
that are bad for get into South America,
Central America,
South America,
the Amazon just to huge areas of land that were very,
very offered.
Great potential for,
for for human occupation.
Dogma has said there were no humans there.
Now,
the first bits of evidence are coming out that says there were humans there,
and if that's the case,
then we must consider the possibility that the story of civilization might've
begun in the Americas.
Not In the old world at all.
It might be a new world invention,
not an old wooden bench.